back again and it feels so damn good
stuff go on a Monday so nice on a Monday
you feeling good I am feeling good what
are you reading over there you know you
could read just learning here I'm
reading about you know a little bit
about like the Julian Edelman stuff oh
that's kind of grinding your gears
though no I mean I guess what I'm and I
mean I mean I get it a little like I can
I hope Julian elements found clean I
don't want anybody like I'm not here
rooting against Julian Edelman what I
get annoyed about is just when I
constantly read articles and then I look
at comments or I look about people
commenting on TV or whatever the Julian
Edelman cases well if this substance
isn't on the banned substance list you
know how can he be suspended because
cheaters find ways to cheat the system
and find new drugs and I'm not calling
Julian Edelman I'm just saying that
people who invent these drugs and other
high-end sports figures there's new
chemicals new drugs that can't be
detected whatever it may be a lot like
we talked about just before we came on
the BALCO like a lot of that stuff
there's NFL and drug testing companies
wrecked we don't know what these
substances are until they found balco's
later and got to go inside and go all
these are the things we were seeing on
the drug tests and we couldn't figure
out so yeah again I hope he's not guilty
I don't see a lot of those comments for
other NFL players no I don't it's course
a little bit the New England mafia and
that's the way they always you're gonna
do certainly but yeah I'm interested to
see where that case that case goes I'm I
am - apparently he was trying to do the
they didn't handle it prime right which
goes on in every ain't no I was a player
rep it goes on everyone but you can
always find a way they mishandled it you
know didn't they they didn't did they
ask you to see your driver's license
because as opposed to see your driver's
license every time you can find little
things always those were things as a
player rep that I always argued for my
players you're trouble we're well we
have to follow exact protocol this is
the issue in the NFL in my opinion you
know with a player's exact protocol NFL
we can kind of be like 80% protocol and
it's all good yeah and I used to drive
me crazy
well something in the NFL drove me crazy
we're gonna get into Jameis Winston we
have
Oh Sims the Internet a lot of stuff
going on the internet then I don't think
you've seen yet three really good whoa
big offseason some out of left go fields
big show big show
feeling good Oh Dell still doesn't have
a contract
Oh Dell still sitting in the studio with
us HAMP opens up July 25th I believe
believe so
so the 28th is I'm saying the day he
gets it we're officially getting since
28 the July 28th is the day Odell
Beckham jr. so Sims is going to lie 28th
I want to say that unfortunately Alex
Greg KC Chiefs Tom Morrison have an
Isaac's Chris Smith Jeremiah Lopez John
Mara Christian Marineris beat Charlie
Wilson your time has all passed rod
Simba guest June 27th so we'll see if
he's right John Merrick commented I
finally sacked up and paid the man
fortunately it didn't I am sorry
Chris Smith also he described himself as
a spleen taker so they are not in the
right side we you said farewell to your
spleen right and now we're saying
farewell to gene okay I was going to say
the one other thing too with Odell like
what does he do here yet cuz he can't go
and then leave mm-hmm so he's got about
a month to figure this out yeah it's
easy don't show no I mean he's already
born at once if he wants to blow it up
again I mean that's fine
I mean again like he blew it last year
he blew it they started out oh and four
if they started it out Owen four without
Odell Beckham jr. they would have gone
here's 25 billion in cash please come
back but he blew that opportunity he's
got to do it it stinks but it's his only
chance someone needs to know that we're
looking out for him yeah I know I do not
play don't go out there yeah you say you
can't even do individual drills and then
sit out team because once he leaves oh
he could do that he could be a pain in
their ass the whole time he's there too
he could be like oh I don't you know you
know the Giants would be the best way to
handle the Giants go there and kind of
be a pain in the ass or not show up at
all after showing up I think he's going
to go I think he's going I think so too
I think maybe the best way to do with
the Giants is go and don't partake in
teams or anything team wise don't my
season
do the season comes and they still
haven't give you your contract you go go
to the game Oh coach it's week one my
hammies tight yeah hi today because
that's my thing that's been the perfect
soldier in my opinion he has throughout
this entire offseason other than that
one four second clip that was even from
this office right and yeah just don't go
all right so let's go to Jean you talked
about someone coming back after a few
games Jean starett or was the image of
the NFL after the referee strike he goes
out for that Thursday night game tips
his cat like the Italian mobster there's
a greatest impression of him what do you
mean just how you got his mannerisms
down yeah yeah like when he had the
little index card right last year the
first anybody goes a man in this yeah
he's like a guy like if you went to a
hostess table and Italian restaurant
he'd be like you to make a reservation
right I feel like he was like I grew up
with like 90 of him in North Jersey now
he was always your favorite ref it was
always my favorite so there was kind of
an exodus and refs right and that's
where I wanted to start off with Ed
Hochuli and Jeff Triplett left months
ago yeah Terry McCauley and gene starett
or both left over the weekend yeah we
lost for refs for the biggest name refs
right I don't know if it's an exodus I
also think people don't realize it's a
lot better to be the ref in the booth
where you're you're never wrong then the
guy on the field right you know yes
but gene I just I know that he was your
favorite I'm curious even any good genes
territory stories for us I want to get
him on the show oh I know we'll try to
get him on the show I don't know if I
have any great stories for you other
than just gene he was just I really felt
like when I was with gene he was looking
out for the bet the betterment of the
players you could talk to him like a man
he was gonna talk to you like a man
and I really didn't feel like he was
that he was gonna be respectful to our
team their team whatever it may be
he just had a great way about him where
I always felt good when Gene serrator it
was a rough in a game I feel like people
said he was like a Patriots Homer and I
never felt that way
I mean the Patriots have become the
argument for everything this way I mean
my dad literally goes around the country
and I'm with him at times and everybody
goes you're a patriot Homer all you do
is root for the Patriots and then we go
to Boston and everybody goes you hate
the Patriots so I don't know who knows I
think what's interesting is apparently
ESPN was or NBC was gonna interview
cleat Blakeman and the and the NFL
almost lost him too but then NFL pushed
for them to hire triplet huh
and so they saved another guy Wow but
are you just as a player like these are
some of the biggest names that are the
most reliable guys that do Super Bowls
yeah that's going on it's just bigger
than just trying to get TV money yeah I
think this is about the refs have
probably had a little bit of the world
of being under the microscope I think
guys like you know Terry mail call me or
stir it to where like I'm about to be 60
like I'm not gonna sit here and just be
you know [ __ ] on all every week because
I missed one holding call in the second
quarter or something like that I think
there's a little bit of them and I've
just had enough and you know I don't
know where they are financially but I
would think that's the biggest reason
what about [ __ ] TV what about the
fact that they had that new guy running
the reviews what was his name again last
year I mean Ron I mean I'm blanking on
the the reek but the fact that some guy
how River on yeah the guy that wasn't
actually a ref was the one changing all
their calls I just it to me it smells
more than just people cleaning for TV
jobs it feels like an exodus of referees
well it's easily is it gonna be worse
referees next year Aston I would think
so yeah but I mean yeah your genes
territory okay yeah I don't have to
travel all over the country every week
and you know ridiculed publicly they say
I loved Pereira is right and then they
go on TV it's the easy job and you just
talk about the rules of the game and
there's no pressure I think that's
really the angle they're looking for I
didn't know that about the other aspect
though that's that's interested in see
furtive espn.com said cleat Blakeman
audition for NBC ESPN hired triplet
maybe Blakeman would have got more of
the three recently filled gigs dos
territory on CBS McCauley on NBC
welcome to jeans territories referee
when you come in we don't care about
holding we care about pass interference
and of course flag on the play
would you like side of parmesan Thank
You Jean stare at door okay I don't know
he's just so Italian I hey I don't but
that sounded like Mexico that was a
really I'm in the World Cup I'm all over
the place that was not Italia remember
how we said that we need to come up with
a nickname for the Titans running back
do oh yeah edit comments on Arnold
Schwarzenegger and DeVito right Dan Mac
hit me up with a good one Dion Lewis and
Derek Henry the tight twins get it but
guess I get it yes because of twins and
they're the Titans yes that's right
James it's pretty good okay do we
formally accept it as their nickname no
I don't think I'm ready for that yet I
need to hear a few more I got to look
this brainstorm and fester a little in
our brains we don't we got till early
september to come up with their nickname
yes we do all right now it is time I've
been wanting to make this an official
segment for a while show Sims the
Internet
I'm gonna get this kind of queued up
here Sims we're gonna look at my
computer and everyone else I'm really
excited all right first one oh this is
not the body one yet no okay so you know
I already told you told me that I
haven't looked at say quads body but I
might be nah wait here is video of Odell
Beckham jr. dunking showing his health
my first question is this a 10 foot is
this a 10 foot oh I'm not sure about
that he's 511 and when he lands it looks
10 feet it does look it's pretty close
listen I yes I would say so either way I
know he can dunk like that on a 10 foot
whoo but it doesn't matter I mean this
is one of the most explosive people
there is yes I mean that's unbelievable
I'd like to see his jump shot because
there was that video of that bad I agree
all right but impressive you expected it
what do you think oh I expected it
that's this is yeah I mean this is like
these are like what NFL athletes like a
special receiver or DB these are the
kind of things that I've seen before
where this like just as far as whatever
we want to argue what the greatest
athletes in the world are is it hand-eye
is explosive ability all that the
explosive ability aspect of the wide
receiver and the DB yes they could win
dunk competition was it Josh or Luke it
was Luke McCown tell the Luke McCown
story were you in practice training camp
training camp Orlando we used to do
training camp at the wild world of
sports and Disney right we [ __ ]
praying for prayed for rain every day
okay cuz I cuz it was a hundred degrees
and a hundred percent humidity and we
had two a days every day and in Orlando
there was always a thunderstorm off in
the distance and it never came and we
were always like please come and then as
soon as you see a lightning strike this
is the one thing I always loved about
Derrick Brooks cuz he knew like the guys
needing arrest if we saw a lightning
strike Derrick would run off the field
and if Derrick ran off the field
everybody was running off the field sure
he was the boss and the coaches were
gonna be like no Derrick come back yeah
he's like no I'm at Heba screw this and
he'd run but so we go inside leaner yeah
it's a leader it is it's knowing that
the guys needed a little time but we'd
go inside to the basketball courts where
they have these like huge AAU
tournaments and things when we used to
be there but we practice in the in the
gym and you wouldn't do a full practice
like a walkthrough
type of thing right get the plays get
some of those reps and why we're waiting
around they're clearing out the gym
setting it up the way we won a ball
rolls
all around right you guys are taking
some jump shots and whatever and I'm
just sitting there cuz I'm like damn I'm
tired I'm just gonna sit here and wait
until we start this crap and all sudden
get ball rolls
I see Luke McCown who I knows a good
athlete a good basketball player but I
use kind of tech Louisiana Tech and I
haven't seen him in action yet so he
shoots a jump shot and oh my god that's
a nice little jump shot
but the next one he shoots a jump shot
and he shoots it like 10 feet short and
I'm like what and he kind of does it
Odell Beckham does right there he
bounces it and he runs up and gets it
and throws it between his legs
Vince Carter style and dunks it and if
you want to think our team was tired our
team woke the [ __ ] up right there I was
like whoa it's not who commands a
quarterback and it's a white guy and
it's double-whammy brother right a
triple and it wasn't like he did it like
knock it over the rim it was like it was
like in the air hang there for a second
and like wow like it was unbelievable
and then everybody was like woah do was
something else yeah and it just became a
Luke McCown dunk fest he was I mean yeah
he's phenomena he was like Luke I'm
gonna say is like 6 2 or 3 so all the
McCallum brothers can ball oh yeah
they're phenomenal athletes like
phenomenal like was a 4/5 so Chris and
Matt versus Josh and Luke you guys are
getting your ass kicked
oh yeah because Matt's not gonna hold up
Matt was an average basketball player he
can't mess with this no one sent me an
article that the Pittsburgh Steelers
were thinking about making Matt Simms
their quarterbacks coach and then I
looked and it spelled sy mm es there's
another guy I had people texting me
today and I was like where is this kid
they're like are we gonna get good
Steeler stories now that Matt's coaching
quarterbacks denying it to Bo and they
weren't believe me they kept sending me
texts asking I was like listen I don't
know what you're hearing but no way you
shaped as my brother will not be working
for the Steelers I had like just say it
that way they're like oh okay I guess I
believe you guess why mm es okay so
that's where that came from couldn't
figure it out Matt sue okay all right
now another one for show center
quarterback coach here is Tom Brady
singing YouTube
all right and it was obviously brought
to you from the TMC I like Tom hight
puts himself out there yeah you like
that I mean yeah tom is such a good guy
again how would you think of his voice
is horrible it was hard but and I also
do wonder but I guess listen this is
something maybe I can't comprehend
because I'm not a superstar I I always
look at those things and go damn you've
got to film yourself in the middle of
the best song of YouTube what's weird is
is I was looking at Giselle he's like
broadcasting it live right and I'm like
man were rich famous people are like I
don't know if it's for your fans or
right now so maybe it is and I
understand they are trying to share it
with their fans because people do and
tenth Lea follow them at all that tom is
a great dude I know that know how being
a u2 fan is so predictable yeah okay it
is it is yeah yes like I think Tom's
very well-rounded though I think Tom's
you think he listens to a lot of those
hip hop no but he knows all the
mainstream songs whether or whatever
John root is to me it's more proof that
everyone thinks they're a good singer at
a concert and then when you listen to
those videos later battery my girlfriend
have like an Earth Wind and Fire where
it's like dead data and like when we
listen to the audio we create like that
it's the worst yes
yeah but tom brady and giselle yeah
that's they actually like each other
they definitely like each other and yeah
you know again Tom Tom I like I've
always said because I always I'm
fighting this battle because I even pass
people in New York Street they're like
Tom Brady's also really like I'm like I
know my god just a Boston fans yell at
me I know and they'll go he's the best
quarterback and I'll go no he's third
sorry or fourth I don't let them off on
that one
fourth there's first like I know I know
more than you know he's fourth that's
how it goes right but yes he's a normal
dude and he's I know just because of my
Jersey friends that used to be friends
with him are still our friends I know
they're not around him as much anymore
but they always used to rave about him
all right all right let's go now
apparently Christiano Ronaldo doesn't
skip leg day legs and ass what do you
think of those hands well that's really
good I've seen Christiano Ronaldo in
purse
no from a distance he's way smaller and
skinnier than the muscle definition
looks like on TV right so he is ripped
like shredded wheat I mean he's got a
nine pack he is Jack ripped from that
standpoint and tremendous shape but yeah
I don't like that like I don't think he
is the same muscle density as you know
like like a say Quan we're gonna see in
a Cristiano Ronaldo what's his what's
his measurements I don't know but I have
this for you the grand Earl said
Christiano was clocked at 21.1 miles per
hour with the ball at his feet in the
World Cup for net was 20 to 105 I know
that they're wearing pads right he's
carrying a ball that's different
there's de listen you think it's harder
to run with a ball in your hand than
dribbling a ball well he's kicking it
and then running after it as fast as he
can so he's not carrying it in between
when he's getting clocked he's he's not
like attached to his foot he's going
sideways 21 miles the balls in your hand
you don't have to just change your
stride at all well if he kicks it out
there far enough he gets to open up and
go but you're also holding an object
that's not letting you actually take
advantage of running form yeah no race
ever will Christiano Ronaldo beat
Leonard fournette and I can promise you
that sir ever well maybe when like
Leonard's been hitting 9 million times
I'd like to race hey George alright
we're going to say Quan do not take this
one full I'll do this one in post so I
just I want you to mainly focus on
sims's reaction here okay he's just I
wanted to get a weight on Christiana I
mean I would say yeah I don't know yeah
he's 6 1 I just don't know the weight
I'd be interested to know that all right
don't worry are you ready I am ready I
can't wait my favourite ass and legs on
the world right now I have put three
pictures of say Guam Berkeley on the
Simpson Lefko Instagram account from the
ESPN Body Issue yeah they're the three
pictures that I found to be the most
impressive that really focus on the legs
and ass I don't care about his biceps or
just somebody else - just - okay I don't
care about his back I don't care about
his I know it has to make like pass like
big time because
woody the makeup girl was like in all
this she was like it's sensation yeah so
Sims I
present to you say Quan Berkeley shake
wad Berkeley legs and ass let's say it
damn holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] his hamstring
muscle hold on I gotta pull that over to
me a little bit his hamstring muscle
what the [ __ ]
look at that thing alright you wanna see
another one
man that is unbelievable that to me is
the most impressive one that's one of
the most impressive handles I've ever
seen let me get it back hold on one of
the most impressive hamstrings I've ever
seen how about that one whoa whoa big
offseason man look how it's like
connected to the middle of his body
perfect
it's like truly like this is what you
build if you were in a lab like I want
perfect human let's see the next one
damn I mean I mean listen his ass and
legs are amazing his back the definition
and his back in his body is just
unbelievable I mean that's that's not
even a Christmas tree on his back that's
like more intricate than a Christmas
tree he's got Christmas tree and
decorations so in all the locker rooms
you've been and all the athletes you've
been around you've never seen have you
ever seen something like this yeah I
mean whoo I don't know to this extent
quite this one to me is the one that's
insane
I don't know if I've seen it to this
extent I guess this is where I would say
I've seen body parts on a guy that are
similar to that but he's got every body
part that's like that where I go WOW
like right like Michael Pittman okay or
Thomas Jones when I played running they
played running back for the Bucks their
upper body was like that right right but
they didn't have the ass and legs that
were quite like that to look like that
sorry
he goes into another level Derrick
Brooks he had an ass and legs like that
really but he didn't have the upper body
like he does that's quite that dense and
ripped like that so there's guys I've
seen along the way Brandon Marshall has
some set of legs and ass on him if I
asked you do you have more confidence
now and say go on after seeing that do
you know because my confidence is next
are you gonna go home and I like on your
way home today on the train you just
gonna look at those pictures a little
bit more no I probably at some point
tonight though maybe after a tequila or
something like that I'm gonna be like oh
I forgot to show I'm gonna show my wife
only maybe you got to see this [ __ ]
sake well after tequila sounded so weird
reactions going to be here's what I want
you to do with your phone Phil man yeah
I like the new Harvey Show be she'll be
amazed she'll be like oh my gosh is that
real like it's incredible though the
hamstring one is out of the first one
the first one he looks like he has a
rhinoceros like Cage like how they're
like they have their protection armor
around his hamstring Oh like it looks
like he has pretty like inside of his
it's like here's this inside we have
armor around his hamstrings incredible
about me I don't know if people out
there like this as someone that is not
jacked I still think that that is
possible for me if that was my job yeah
no I don't think this is the first body
I've ever looked at I was like I can
like I when I saw Edelman yeah it was
like if I really tried but say Kwan I go
there's it's impossible no never seen
anything that's impossible you that you
I think have great DNA you could be like
a jack trip guy I do think that I don't
know the discipline now you know
definitely not sorry sweating right now
but but the thing that I think would
kill you about a sake one that is really
break your heart and what breaks my
heart when I've been around guys like
this is it's like hey I'm not trying to
say he's not a hard worker
but it's limited work that he has to do
to look like that I don't know man he's
a hard one that's power cleaning for
something he's working at that I'm
saying if he was lifting weights once a
week he wouldn't be far off from there
and you'd go up damn that's pretty
unbelievable body I think he's that
gifted he worked hard incredible and it
gives it a little more the striations
and things like that you see over under
me and Joe we're talking about this
earlier over-under 1500 total yards for
him that's gone over yeah Wow I think
he's gonna be around the 1819 hundred
mile yeah I do I think he's gonna be
like it's gonna
right or you know 3200 rushing 6 or 500
receiving Wow I think that's the type of
year where it's you don't say I think
the big thing is schirmer's offense yeah
which I kind of a knife a lot of faith
in it right right but I think sometimes
we look at the left side of their
offensive line I don't want to make this
about the Giants offensive line again
there's still holes in that offensive
line short I still don't have faith in
Eli and I think that means a lot yeah I
get you and we'll see what happens with
Odell all right we're gonna stay with
legs and ass let us go back to the
computer screen
deshaun Watson do you notice anything
there he's wearing glasses well screw
the glasses we're talking asses oh he's
got some Duncan dunk there I didn't know
that the show and Watson had that oh
well you know if they're fast they
usually got badonkadonk oh that's that's
was even the body issue no okay that was
just a random picture marveling at just
how cool he looks in his uniform alien
OTAs when he's wearing the blue hoodie
and he's I mean he just got that like
cool he can dress up in the uniform it
looks good man all right last one
the clasp is real though I don't know if
there's everybody wearing glasses these
days that makes you look smarter man all
right so last one I don't think it'll
make me look smarter count the plates
[Music]
Aaron Donald no pause five plates five
plates on each is that for 90 180 270
360 360 it's for 50 it's four plus the
bar
yes 45 45 yeah and he's doing it was
like a t-shirt over his arm yes I don't
really understand what he's doing and a
pretty close grip bench to to wear and
then there was no pause it was just like
oh I'll bounce it off my chest and just
keep going usually people like yeah ed
needed somebody to touch the bar a
little so 495 for Aaron Donald's
I mean he's look we're at a time where I
think there's a number of guys the NFL
that have never existed before I don't
think an Aaron Donald has ever existed
before I don't think he's like it's like
it's like a say Kwan has ever existed
before I would argue with bo Jackson and
people like that it existed but I get
what you're saying and I think you're
right let them settle our time proved
they're ahead of their time you're right
you're right like it's it's like we talk
it's like we talk about Josh Allen I
said Josh Allen's the modern-day Troy
Aikman this is the way they're made 30
years down the road so yeah I get that I
think we're seeing that a lot of sports
you know that's my one of my arguments
when we would talk about LeBron James
like our Michael Jordan Michael Jordan
damn
there was no Dirk Nowitzki's or Kevin
Durant in the NBA when Michael Jordan is
playing so the league is different and
yes Aaron Donald is like what he's your
new age warren sapp he's the more incept
that likes to work out and have muscles
that's the thing else there's a number
of guys the NFL right now that are
because of science and because of
nutrition yeah they're not resting on
just talent no they're not they've been
raised in an environment because of the
culture we are in our country right now
you're right where its eighth grade it's
like oh we're getting specific now and
shoot the video of LeBron James's kid
trying to dunk I watched it I didn't
know he was dating right I didn't know
he was 13 I thought the kid was 16 or 17
my little boy watches him daily that's
what's incredible yes these kids are
gonna be celebrities before they even
play loves him he's all he's all in on
LeBron
already alright well that was something
that actually followed Jameis Winston
and we're gonna get to him now yeah
Jameis Winston was a guy that was famous
for a very long time he was famous in
high school he was famous when he went
to college and famous Jameis was lying
at his anus so something happened a
little bit ago where Winston was accused
of groping a female 2016 I believe
driver right he was with we knew Ronald
Darby model Darby came out and said we
were in the car together there was a
third person right the identity of that
third person came out and his name was
Brandon banks former Vanderbilt football
player who is in prison for rape yes so
that was the third memory the other
detail that came out was that Jameis was
not in the same car that he was put into
a separate car and then all of their
stories fell apart no and their stories
it sounded like they were all in the car
together earlier that night and they
tried to act like the late night car
ride was that one which doesn't sound
like it was and so when that information
came out the NFL went well you're all
lying right Jameis you're suspended for
three games right it's been an
up-and-down ride for Jameis Winston thus
far and it's happening right around
contract negotiation time yeah they
still have that fifth year option would
be for the year afterwards which would
be about twenty million dollars and this
is typically where you would negotiate a
long-term deal yeah you know this
franchise you know the McKay's what are
you doing with Jameis Winston right now
the Glazers excuse me yes no I think the
Glazer family is probably I knowing them
they're probably disgusted right now to
a degree they really are they're such
good people they don't want this type of
stigma on their franchise or being
associated with it this definitely hurts
the future of Jameis Winston and Tampa
Bay and you know the fifth year option
had they officially I don't think it I
don't think they have yet so they can at
this point you cannot do it I think they
may have extended it have that person
please do because I'm not even sure
about that either
I thought they maybe did too which makes
this thing very complicated as well yeah
picked it up in April yes what I thought
so the thing that makes it complicated
to because of the the simple fact that
it's guaranteed now right there I
actually think that makes it better for
them I think the fact that it happened
in April they could say oh you guys knew
this but you could the team get it can
resend it we didn't start of the next
league year so they can do that and this
was something right they could certainly
be the type of offense that is a rescind
able 50 or contract option offense the
problem is here is it's just a pattern
right and I I can't really defend Jameis
Winston on this subject anymore it's
like where there's smoke there's fire
and it's just been too much smoke and
added to the fact that we're hearing
that there might have been an even and
this is allegedly okay so but we're
hearing that there might have even been
another sexual assault case before the
one at Faridah state that had originally
been swept under the rugs we're hearing
because there's gonna be this report
that comes out but I think the main
thing is this you know the the uber
driver does not look like she's doing
this for any personal gain right
she's went through all the appropriate
channels without calling the police for
a long long time in this certain matter
so I don't look at this as a certain
that doesn't have the appearance of me
if somebody's trying to make a name for
themselves or just out to get somebody
because they're famous no I think this
awesomely happens is another female
exactly yeah right so there's there's
just too many instances right now for
Jameis Winston where I'm disappointed
because I've been a defender of him yeah
and I didn't judge too critically about
the Florida State incident and this
makes me rethink all of it and I give
him none of the benefit of the doubt
from here on out so I was curious I was
like I feel like I've talked about this
before after week 9 the Monday after
week 9 this is what I said saying I was
wrong and I do think he's a guy anymore
and I think that all of this was an act
and I fell hook line and sinker for it
and I don't see any of the talent I
don't see the composure and I also don't
believe that this team believes he's a
leader and he misses after him what I'm
just saying I'm reading what I saw
yesterday I am out on Jameis Winston
being a future quarterback franchise
quarterback in the NFL I know that I'm
going harsh yeah but I believe that
what I've seen thus far this season
alder cutter no it's a lot of dumb plays
every week by the guy and what I saw
from him collective yesterday I think
I've been read I've been falling victim
to a really good sermon and now I'm
realizing that no one's listening to
that [ __ ] anymore yeah that was right
after he was like picking fights on the
sideline and all that stuff the Panthers
game when he would not wanted to run out
in the field and fight the referee I
think this was the Saints case all right
so that's to eat the W the game so
that's not even to the point where the
few weeks later was the Panthers game
right where he actually played well and
they had that bad call at the end and he
wanted to run out in the field we were
sold Jameis Winston the beginning I
think the way we were sold him was the
reason we've put up with all of this in
terms of he's such a gamer it's his life
he's been drawing plays since he's been
five it's passion the pregame speeches I
to me this feels like somebody with with
living a double life yeah and I feel
like he was so committed he's got the
eye contact we've been around him we
know how passionate charisma is
off-the-charts and I think it's covered
a lot of us told us yes I was already
out on Jameis Winston yeah and now I'm
really out yeah
what's funny is I texted you my first
thought business-wise was you could
offer Jameis half a contract right now
and try and use this as leverage
yeah like signed to a four-year deal for
like 50 million right and maybe you
could lock him up but I would even say I
don't know if his plays been that
deserving no no you can't do that and
you can you can't afford him to be the
face year franchise in any shape way or
form right now at this moment like don't
even try to get him for the low canva
baby Buccaneers you got to see how this
all plays out think about the Hard
Knocks yeah Dirk cutter look frustrated
dealing with Sheerness with all of his
issues constantly constant brain fart he
has some moments where he looks in
crisis and great the last three games of
the year he played as good as anybody in
football that's great great against that
Panthers yes he played great against
that was that the Falcons late in the
year I feel like he plays better when
he's down 14 I hear you there and you
know again left coated your point though
I think you're right again it's like
goes back to the like where there's
smoke there's fire
Jimbo Fisher had these same issues yeah
Dirk that Dirk cutter had as well I mean
we saw that on the sidelines all the
time in this
tell him to shut his ass up and walk
back you know you shut your door sit on
the bench I'm a bench you whatever it
was
so I caused that clip to go viral but
there's other day I found I recorded Oh
Mike my TV it's the first time I've ever
had a tweet have like thousands of
retweets and I was like he just said sit
the [ __ ] down on the bench and I like
put it online it was my first ever tweet
that's funny yeah big moment for you
thanks but yeah I'm done defending
gameís you're done I'm done I'm done
defending I'm actually done rooting for
him as a whole right now yeah I feel
like him this is the offseason or the
year of our the offseason of I feel
betrayed by Jameis or I actually feel
like a fool like he's fooled me right
like honey you said he's his talk and
his charisma has fooled me into
something too many issues here and this
is my last draw of this and it sounds
like he was guilty and I know we'll find
out all that stuff I'm actually shocked
at the NFL cut it down from six to three
with his history I'm shocked by that if
there was one time to justify six games
it was this one for this guy I mean from
the history standpoint and what he's
done yeah so I feel that bad and I feel
I'm feel cheated by Joe Flacco to like
again like Joe [ __ ] was another guy like
him I'm never gonna stick him what
happened Joe Flacco the last few years
just the way he's played the way he's
talking about that's different that's
play yeah I know I know I'm just saying
those are two guys that I look at I
can't look at the same I'll say this too
let's self scout yeah we both took
Jameis over Mariota and said it wasn't
close right think about where they are
right now yeah
Mariota caught a pass to himself and
overcame a 2103 deficit in an arrowhead
right and and wasn't bad against the
Patriots there's more the Titans defense
and that team is on the rise and now
Jameis is sitting here facing a
three-game suspension who knows what's
gonna happen in the future and and his
play has not been as good just another
example of the Maurya Mariota was the
guy he was the mature guy he was
impressed this is again it's just
another example of we were wrong I'm
just gonna say this Mariota was the PEC
and I guess we didn't factor enough the
personal but I would also say like if
you were to ask me who's been playing
better it's really tidy oh just on the
field
oh yeah it's close it's very close no
doubt about it
yes I mean if you like Mariota starting
to gain that bravado to take more
chances and Jameis has not learned to
how to pull it back back yeah I think
you're right they're opposite ends of
the spectrum there and again we knew
Mariota was Johnny professional coming
out in the draft that's all everybody
talked about and we knew Jameis was
dicey we did and we kind of liked that
we did we kind of liked it exactly right
and of course he was clutch and big
moments and Faridah stayed some of those
games they wouldn't have won without him
but yes there is no doubt that Mariota
was the pick that that debate is over
and Jameis Winston I think his career is
it's a little bit in trouble here to
who's gonna want to sign Jameis Winston
as a free agent next year I'm just
saying it's gonna be an issue there's
gonna be I would say we just saw guys
like Hackenberg get another chance
Jameis has actual talent right and we
they overlooked domestic violence the
final time I know they do I think it's
being looked on a little bit more now
there were teams really just very
engaged yeah like he needs to grow up
big-time
Jericho k-7 hit me up on the DMS for
Sims Lefko and said man I as a Bucs fan
I I hate going through this I wish we
drafted Josh Allen and just like kind of
moved on right there all that hurts he
said but this topic is relevant I have a
question for Sims being the fact that he
was a Buccaneer quarterback for a while
his Jameis Winston already the best
quarterback to play for the Bucs
not the greatest that's Brad Johnson
Doug Williams one of those guys right
but as Jameis better than those three
guys already in the short time in the
NFL no I'm not gonna say he is you know
he has more talent than Brad Johnson and
I'm not trying to say anything bad about
Brad you know Brad was a hell of a
quarterback and can manage a team and
brought other things to the table to to
lead a team Doug Williams no that's the
guy oh man Doug is Mark said that people
don't appreciate they don't realize how
talented he was only know his place in
the history books I don't never saw him
play yeah it was special to see in
person the ball it was a little bit
first african-american quarterback to
witness exactly right and he was a
little bit of a one of those guys that
guy would almost attribute to a little
bit like a Jeff George
and I saw him in person when he was
playing against my dad where Wow arm
more moon same thing like you were in
the stands and you just said man like me
you know hey big Phil Simms he can throw
it but damn that ball from them is
really spinning and going down the field
in a hurry so why is he never mentioned
because I just don't think he had the
longevity he dealt with the issues he
came in as a backup quarterback won that
Super Bowl had a little success then
started to have little injury issues and
never really had that sustained period
of time to where think about it he won
the Super Bowl in 87 they won the Super
Bowl in 91 with Mark rippen right so he
only had like a three or four year run
and but his physical ability in his arm
I know he's one of the guys my dad will
always rave about that it'll go oh he's
one of the greatest throwers to ever
play the sport yeah Sheamus Jameis sucks
man it does suck
but you know what you are who you hang
out with you know yeah you are what you
do yeah and you just caught he's just
constantly done bad and I can't just
treating women like this constantly is
just to the school talk last year
remember that when he was talked about
and he was like telling women that they
need to just be quiet and sit in their
place and men are Superman
right back to me so that should that I
think now with this and we had an
inkling but I think now piecing it all
together that's why I go back to it's
hard for me to defend him at all now all
right let's not try and sure it up a
little bit with whoa big season
apparently people are just walking down
the street to Simms don't know what to
say and they just say whoa big offices
yes they do
I had one walking out of the office on
Thursday it was great that's awesome I
know the ultimate whoa big off season
continues for Davis Webb the headline of
the article oh my god Davis Webb refuses
to stop working during Giants pre-camp
break whoa time off [ __ ] that Davis
Webb's working right cuz every
quarterbacks just going I'm not touching
a football until I go back to training
camp that's right that's what made all
these quarterbacks good Davis Webb is
first gonna travel back to his hometown
in Texas and spend time with his dad
who's the coach of prosper high school
he's gonna train throw and steady game
tape during this time he also plans to
increase his running to get an axe
in shape you might spend some time with
a personal trainer in New Jersey here's
where it gets great
who wrote this can you tell me that very
high on those nj.com again this seems to
be like they're in bed with this guy
just before the team broke after
minicamp
Webb organized a private meeting at the
facility with the Giants coaching staff
in search of four or five bullet points
of things he needs to work on during the
time off some of them increased
knowledge of the offensive line
protection schemes better understand why
certain routes are called by Pat Shermer
improve his efficiency from a footwork
standpoint whoa he's just sharing
everything I mean is this like left cold
PR it's incredible I mean it's unreal we
I have Giants fans in this office or
like he's the net he's dragons a he's
getting he's getting be able to buy in
not so when you better be incredible
that point where he said what was it
right after OTAs we called the some of
the coaching staff in to give him four
or five people always men yeah hey come
in I'm the bat third string quarterback
second string quarterback sorry guys
come in he organized a private meeting
so maybe he just said hey guys can I get
a quick meeting yes yeah hey listen it
sounds like he's doing everything well
that's great let's keep doing it yeah
but you're getting a little perturbed
well I just I you know again none of
this crap matters this is like that's
why it's like the crap you always hear
about backup quarterback stone you know
you've heard my dad reg rant about this
crap and I'm gonna rant about it now -
it is you don't understand that whoa big
offseason is to show how ridiculous this
[ __ ] is I know I understand it it just
still doesn't mean it doesn't drive me
crazy I mean yes I would hope he was
going home to do these things I mean
Aaron Rodgers and Tom Brady aren't just
sitting there with like pina coladas in
their hand the whole five weeks like Ben
Roethlisberger's might be it's not a
pina coladas definitely beer but like
Ryan Fitzpatrick was like [ __ ] Jameis
now I gotta try cold my beer was gonna
take training camp to get in shape and
work on my throwing but now I'm gonna
have to go in and actually be good you
know which quarterbacks do you think are
having pina coladas turning this month
I mean Big Ben is certainly one that I
have a little
and go he's not like Ben's gonna go out
and have a few throwing sessions all of
a sudden is like putting down the Pina
Colada Flacco's haven't throw it well we
made fun of that let's see if anybody
else jumps out to me there I mean it's
not gonna be many other Flacco's been on
the pina coladas Philip Rivers is gonna
be ready to go Andy Dalton Derek Carr
what do you think Eli thinks reading all
these articles about David he's probably
like dude come on he probably thinks
it's funny well it's just yes it's
actually really good for Eli because
when Davis Webb doesn't end up playing
that great in pre-season and everyone's
built into their mind that he's the
replacement option it just makes a lie
little embarrassing yeah you're right
about that I think I think so yeah it's
all gonna come down to the preseason
anyways Davis Webb's got a show show his
ass and preseason football and show that
all this stuff is paying off I've
actually thought about this before when
do you think Eli the Giant should have
moved on from Eli hmm what year after
the after the Packers game the tenant
sick season was hard to move on at that
point so that was what mm you know that
was 2016 season
there's just cheers ago so 2070 is that
last year
yeah that's last year should have moved
on what week well I mean yes and my
thought they should I mean they're the
joshan conversation could have been
there
yes Geno certainly Geno played one of
the best games of the year at the
quarterback position I just
we should start referring to Eli as this
is the post-retirement
Eli like we thought Eli should have
retired when they went to Geno like week
14 of last year everything since and
continuing on from now is post
retirement Eli well it's certainly not
the end Eli I know that and again get
back to that to like when do you draw
the line to go okay we're gonna move on
if it's hard to go move on after 2016
because they go to the playoffs even
though it was an impressive offensive
play or quarterbacking so it is hard to
move on in that aspect gonna be harder
when se Kwang's legs and ass are pumping
out 1,800 yards yeah yeah it's back and
Evan Engram looks good you're exactly
right over think they're gonna realize
the weakness they have an Eli until it's
too late
no they you're exactly right they're
gonna
they're in this boat with Eli for two
more years and yes the ladies all have
to watch for again Eli's the biggest
question mark on the team but the other
thing is it's not gonna be against the
crap teams of the world it's gonna be
can Eli Manning when we get into the
playoffs or late in December against
some playoff caliber defense
consistently make some of those plays to
get them over the edge to win football
games that what it'll all come back to
and we promise that if Eli looks good
out there we're gonna shut the [ __ ] up
and we'll take the beating yes I hope he
does I hope you like comes back looking
amazing I am like waiting I'm taking the
beating I have yeah because I think it's
gonna be he's gonna have big yard it'll
be like a Jared Goff see so that's what
I mean it's gonna be good enough to
where people are gonna go look it's
pretty damn good as stats are good and
I'm gonna go okay yeah but it's you know
90 screens and whatever else but the
Giants are gonna be good I would be
shocked if they're not all right whoa
big offseason a player's banner removed
this one actually came from a fan Jimbo
slice 27 Jimbo you're the man welcome
both he writes whoa big Earl Thomas hold
out update I'm a Seattle native and
outside our stadium on the walls the
Washington Mutual Convention Center
pictures of Seahawks crates
Russell Wilson Doug Baldwin Bobby Wagner
just want to let you guys know that as
of yesterday they replaced Earl Thomas's
face with Shaquille Griffin could this
mean the end of Earl Thomas and Seattle
face removal whoa big offseason Wow
don't know if that's confirmed I haven't
seen anywhere except Jimbo slice 27 have
you ever seen have you ever been on the
team where a guy's face has been removed
from a wall have your has your I think
mine was removed from the side of the
stadium so you were like on the Bucks
wall yeah I was on like the s-1 what is
it like to see yourself on the wall it
is to have a huge banner on the side of
the stadium even though my dad was Phil
Simms when I saw that the first time
I've said whoa big offseason I'm pulling
the [ __ ] off the highway and taking a
picture of this [ __ ] yeah I mean that's
when I was like I made this his dream
come true stuff this is why I work so
hard this is why I didn't go out on
Friday nights at Texas or in high school
because I was dreaming of having a
banner as a starting quarterback on the
side of the stadium so that was your
holy crap am i one of mine certainly
where I was like wow I remember my wife
was in the car and I was like whoa I was
a look at that and I pulled off I pulled
off to the side of the where the Yankees
do spring training because that's right
across this right and I was like holy
cow and I think I got my phone out and
whatever it made a video or whatever it
was yeah that was big time for me
there's something to that I want to see
that story continue I want to see
everything let's do single chord um but
yes Jimbo slice Seahawk Scout if you're
watching somebody go drive by the
stadium and let us know before
Wednesday's podcast recording and we'll
dive into steeper but yeah little
signals like that like when I complained
about Jon Gruden and the fact that I
felt like he was running me out of town
and not treating me fairly the big
picture next to his office was moved out
of the way cuz apparently he didn't want
to look at it it was you it was me a
huge picture of me life-size right
outside his office and everybody told me
he didn't want to look at it and he told
him to move it after you made a public
come after I was like yeah I almost died
nine months ago now they're trying to
cut me like I kind of started to push
back in that narrow they replace you
where I don't ski probably something
like that gosh free what about Bruce but
yes I that got moved so those again
those are little things to look at sure
and that tells you that to me that what
tells me is they're not sure if he's
gonna be on the team that they maybe the
trade or if he's gonna hold out they're
gonna move on with new faces to
publicize Wow they picked the wrong
Griffin put Shakima up there that's the
heartwarming story oh I was thinking it
was him all along you know I did too
until I thought no it's Shaquille his
brother the corner we couldn't find
somebody else better than that that
shows you about the depth of the senior
roster that's right exactly right this
is a year we're gonna have a big betting
show I think before the year I kind of
want to do it at like a casino where we
actually maybe make our bets yeah I have
a lot of people DMing saying I made a
lot of money on the Vikings and Saints
last year when are you doing your
division winners we like to wait until
middle the preseason I guess that's when
we did it right watch a little let me
yeah like I got the people are still
getting hurt I don't wanna make
predictions yet exactly you haven't even
hit a CLC well and I do like the reason
I was on the Saints last year is because
remember I'm in the preseason I was like
their defense looks nominal yes and of
course I started to backtrack after the
first two weeks and they went know it
too I was like oh [ __ ] I guess I watch
that preseason game between Kansas City
and Minnesota and said these are two
playoffs yes right and they were yes
they were you could just see it you it's
it's because after the first season of
preseason immediately all the backups
come in and with the Vikings it was
these guys could start for another time
and it's important to see that it is no
one factors in depth alright last one
off season is it good to be friendly
Alex Smith on Jameson Crowder if any of
my friends are listening and you take
Jameson Crowder ahead of me in fantasy
I'm pissed I think this is one of my big
sleepers this year he's so easy to read
as a quarterback Alex Smith said body
control body language this is where it
gets interesting yeah he's decisive and
he's so friendly he's always coming back
to the ball always working for you yeah
those are things as a quarterback come
crunch time you know he's gonna work his
tail off to get open you love that as a
quarterback I've never heard of that as
being friendly coming back to the ball
but it makes sense yes that's a very
common phrase and then finally it is yes
he's I've never heard it called then
yeah friendly he's friendly he's gonna
come back and get the ball he's not
gonna let that ball sit there in the air
and let some defender get it he's
friendly to you as the quarterback he
goes and gets it he doesn't let anything
else happen
yeah he's friendly and his ability to
read coverages or even his body language
is what I think he's referral but Wilson
was friendly for Alex no don't break
hard guys again we're gonna have fun for
Charlie check down these guys are very
important I mean for a Charlie checkdown
type of guy because this is where he
wants to go Sheamus is gonna get so many
catches Jamison's Christ yeah I would
think so and of course it's an offense
that's a lot of it's built around what
Jameson can do but that's a special pyre
in the NFL Jameson Crowder is really
good but again here's another guy it's
like the Julian Edelman mould type of
receiver so valuable in the league can
do so many different things and the
value is not really understood until you
get around the
guys and you realize how smart they are
how quick they are in person yeah and
body language as like you're saying a
friendly route runner is so important to
friendliest receiver you hello okay
friendly ones that I had mmm not and
then also who is a great receiver that
is also friendly got you okay so
friendly receivers I I'll say this the
one of the most friendly ones I was ever
with would be I would say to him jump
out to me I kill your mic I could tell
Ike's body
I got great body language it was very
consistent and he was smart I felt like
it was an extra quarterback like even
like we were fooled by the coverage
together he'd be like he would adjust on
the fly and be like oh and you know I
knew what he was thinking he'd be a
friendly guy I kill your Brandon
Marshall was friendly Brandon Marshall
because of his size always made you feel
friendly here I go I feel pretty warm
and cozy throw nothing but his route
running and his body language again were
phenomenal to where he was so consistent
with his body language and certain
things he did with certain routes I was
like I felt ultra confident about like
okay he's getting ready to break he
hasn't broke yet but I'm gonna throw it
out there cuz I know it I've seen him
turn his head this way when he's about
to stick his foot in the ground DB's
notice that stuff too
yeah they do but it's hard and it's also
they can play them off of each other a
little bit right so he can have one body
language for the in cut and one body
language for the out cut I know he's
doing the out cut right right so he can
kind of he can sell it the other sell it
and I go oh he's selling it and here he
is about to bounce back and go where I
thought she's gonna go right so you're
not gonna catch on the great that's a
great receiver that was friendly who are
like notoriously unfriendly but also
great wide receivers oh yeah
Joey wasn't always the greatest friendly
receiver I hope he doesn't listen this
podcast Galloway yeah oh yeah because
gallery was so fast he wasn't like the
best route runner ever and don't get me
wrong he was really awesome but he could
be hard to and the fact that a little
bit like we saw with Jameis Winston and
DeSean Jackson this year he's so fast
and he can run so fast sometimes when
he's not really running as fastest and
then when he does run as fast as it
catches you off guard you're going
damn I didn't see that all week so I
threw the ball at 55 I didn't think he
was gonna run forward one on this way
and now I'm ten yards behind him you
know what I mean so little things like
that not that it was a horrible body
language but for as great as he was it
wasn't the best body language ever so
I'm just thinking about Washington's
receiving corps and I'm thinking about
the quarterback yeah right Paul
Richardson is gonna take the top off
he's going to go high in fantasy drafts
I just think alex is gonna throw it out
there once or twice a game that's not
Alex's throwing pattern no Josh
dachshund is going to get one or two
leap balls a game he's gonna be on the
other outside Jameson Crowder is gonna
be sitting there on linebackers nickel
corners and safeties going which way am
I going right you go that way I'm going
that way Alex Smith I think I could see
him getting a hundred-yard hunter
catches next season what right
definitely he is I would just go to me
please steal him in the draft please do
it he is he's gonna have a huge year not
only because Alex Smith but he's really
good and there's no underrated yes the
team is gonna be really good and you
know the healthy they're like the most
injured team in the NFL my sleeper teams
right now agree they are they're one of
those teams and then you know to your
Paul Richardson Josh Dotson 2.2 you know
I'll say this is where I think Jay
Gruden's gonna be good for Alex Smith
because Jay Gruden's got a great way to
be able to like push your buttons and do
it in a nice jolly way like to wear him
back come on you big ones throw it up
there deeper you know D he'll make it
fun in the meeting like when you're
around John you learn what right but
yeah he'll find some way to make light
of the situation but also be like no you
should have thrown that go route and I'm
not gonna scorn you but I'm gonna make
funny a little until you start making it
more yeah the one guy that would steal
it is a torch happy birthday towards you
just have one but if there's one guy
that's gonna steal my jameson crowder
pic it's him all right let's go do a
little left go PR the NFL made a mistake
that was so egregious that you can't
take their side low-rent
diverting tardif offensive lineman for
the Kansas City Chiefs in accomplish the
impressive feat of graduating from
medical
school after years of taking classes in
the offseason that's amazing
I'll say that to spend your life playing
the NFL and then in the offseason going
to medical school right that's crazy
it's crazy he asked to have MD on his
jersey they are not allowing it to
happen to me it is such an obvious win
that the NFL just blew any when you
think about it if you can put senior
like Steve Smith did on his jersey you
should be able to put MD but that's
officially his name it is harder to be a
doctor than it is to be a dad I don't
know about that you're not there yet so
become a doctor in one night and then
one night no yeah who says you become a
dad in one night might have to be coming
I can become a dad tonight I don't know
if you can I'm not sure by these sounds
let me send a test make sure we linked
up no I don't want to see his MD in the
Jersey
I can't believe we're gonna start
putting bachelor's degree on the back
there too
we get stuff done all three connotations
when you meet someone that has earned
their doctorate you call them doctor
okay but what does one of the other
other ones out there they don't matter
they don't matter no no I think MD is
the only one that you call doctor that's
the only no but so like I mean so what
if a guy passes one other and if all
players have gone through law school
zero is that the only guy okay you're a
league in which we have deteriorating
brains right and we call these guys
unintelligent and someone in their off
season gets an a doctor they want MD I
just think it's opening a can of worms
and I don't really care put it put it on
your license plate I don't want it in
the back your Jersey how about be a good
og
first or be healthy to play first
instead of going to school that's what I
think how about that do you genuinely
feel this I don't want MD on it I don't
care no I don't care I'm just saying I
think it's gonna open up a can of words
do I generally feel like Bachelor of
Science but the crazy NFL players
they're gonna find something they'd be
like oh well he can poke that then I
want to put this on there I just think
that somewhere that it is very rare it's
a great accomplishment I just think
they're opening a cannon works do I am I
gonna be mad that they've let MD and
like really fight you over this No
all right enough go PR the NFL should be
in crisis moto after this
if they publicly give him the MD yes
you're buckling can't do that NFL not
great at social let me give you a little
bit of left go PR hidden-camera reveal
put it in his locker with the MD
stitched on and give the rest of the
team a surgical mask for a release video
oh my god and everyone comes out with
surgical masks and it's like oh the NFL
so great I wouldn't be cool about but I
would say that's the end of the year
they go by the way $60,000 I can't
believe you're against it I don't know
if I'm against are you self-conscious
that you're not that educated that you
didn't actually graduate college no I'm
very conscious of that that I'm not and
I'm very conscious of the fact that I
was joking no I'm still a semester short
and I'm very conscious that I'm not the
smartest yes we go back to school with
goes back to school - that's what sucks
like so yeah I am a semester short
because Island went to school for three
and a half years because of the combine
and the Senior Bowl and I wanted to
train and get ready so I have like four
classes I haven't finished but they all
pertain to my major cuz I've looked into
this what was your major
my mavis history so I was like read back
useful well I know I wasn't financed it
was too hard I couldn't do it it was
really messy so you have awkward classes
do you know what classes they would be
or they just history classes they're
like oh they all have something to do
pertain to the major right where I have
to take them and University of Texas is
a rule where it says you have to take
classes pertaining to your major at the
campus and you can't take them online or
anything so what this family's not oh
wow I have to show my kids that movie
this weekend I've been telling them
about it I enjoy rules I need you to go
back to school you need me to if we can
start doing BR stuff in the off season
from Austin Texas I'm down you'd have to
be there the whole I see so yeah and I
don't want to go back to school no they
haven't definitely I want Texas in the
spring time is hot as crap
I was yeah my friend that's their Alex
Michell heart was like I was like the
best thing about Texas man is when you
sweat no one judges each other you just
sweat I was like I don't know man I
sweat different oh man it was brutal I
used to go to class cuz I get done with
a workout and then you know to rush to
class and one of my problems with
getting so many tickets in college is
because of that you just pull up and
park right in front of the class right
in front and that's where my dad my dad
VA Christopher I could have got your
private limo for all the stuff you
charge to the you know all the all the
tickets you guys cuz I get boots on my
car damn oh I'd get it off and yes
called dad
yeah called mom actually mom but you
wouldn't put the bike so the other
accomplishments no matter though like
bachelor's degree cares about about some
of the other ones out there I don't even
know that what they asked her masters I
mean who in the NFL has those who in the
NFL has those I just think he might be
the only like doctor that's actually
playing in the NFL right maybe he can
ask the TV networks to at least refer to
him there they could put his name on
there as MD doctor Yes Doctor
my girlfriend has a doctorate so I just
start referring to as a doctor you
should yeah doctor she's she's a crazy
doctor for dating you alright we're
going out of left go field and we're
going out of Sims field out of left go
field first the Patriots will likely not
be having any joint practices this year
whoa you didn't hear that she did not
see this typically Bella checks club has
worked out with with teams that they
face in preseason games one and two huh
they get those week-long joint practices
right well the first two opponents are
Washington and Philadelphia Washington
has a unique partnership with the city
of Richmond during training camp which
would make that trip to New England
difficult and Doug Peterson came out
last week and said we're not doing joint
practices they said why he said because
he knows why yeah I don't need to share
it well yeah and he might be playing on
the super ball again this year and he
just played him in the Super Bowl and
there's bad blood and all those things
Patriots have held joint practices since
2012 right
I think this could be an issue for the
page can be your right because of the
scheduling the Washington and yeah I
mean I understand that the Washington
Philadelphia I don't blame them why
would you want I'm not even sure New
Englander to want to do that either no
that could lead to fights injuries that
is personal in people's mind still but
we talked about the Patriots they like
joint practices right they get to work
against a different team not get beating
up their own players yeah also they get
to scout some guys and there's been
articles written that every year after
they've joined practice with a team
they've taken a guy from a practice
squad or from their roster come on I've
not been saying that's a Garrett Blount
like like they eventually three Mike
Daniels from the Saints when he when I
was there he was on the Patriots the
next year right it's yes so every grow
kind of feels like the end of an era we
always say don't practice what the
Patriots yes I don't make it I don't
think it is gonna happen I look at their
preseason schedule to the other team you
can look at to go would they be into it
as the Carolina Panthers I could see
that being a team that would make sense
you know both old school coaches gonna
be physical right gonna get everything
they want I think their players listen
to their coach you know you get to the
the problem with that is it's the third
preseason game and I think a lot of
times they're not wanting to give her it
on a bright this get the preseason
practices and I feel like because there
are so many Belichick disciples around
the league Detroit Tennessee they're
scooping up a lot of joint practices
with people yes and they did Washington
a few years ago right right when they
went down there cuz rg-31 to go over and
pick Tom's brain and tells me that way -
you're not playing anymore and then I'll
tell you my tricks so yeah that's I
still think that Washington one thing is
gonna happen I bet you like if they play
its August 9th I bet you maybe August 6
or August 7th they have some sort of
practice against each other just a
little shaker room likes that I don't
think Jay loves that no I would not know
I definitely when you're taking our
advice yes we've asked all these years
don't practice with the Patriots it's
finally happening what did we find out
with Jacksonville right right in our
girl who was it for ESPN Rossini
Diana Rossini broke it out Super Bowl
number one thing
that the the Patriots used to beat the
Jaguars was all their film from training
Kings actly
its brakes its brakes its signals that
maybe haven't changed that they saw all
and they were damn they're still doing
that same signal and you know they
didn't change that one whatever it may
be it just feels like doing joint
practices with the Patriots is like I
know what you did last summer
yes where it's like oh let's stay in
that cabin where three people have died
no stop going in the cabin yet right
agreed all right sit out of Sims feel
well what field is this is a center or
right field so Ron Parker signed with
the Falcons there has been an issue with
safeties so you're not getting jobs in
the NFL Trey Boston came out recently
and said he got a very disrespectful
awful from the Cardinals he said that
when he met with the Colts GM Chris
Ballard didn't meet with him head coach
Frank Reich didn't meet with him not
even the defensive coordinator
coordinator Matt ever flus met with him
Wow so Trey Boston's like and he said in
his article all us safeties need to
stick together right and not take the
minimum I remember
Kenny Vaccaro still out there Eric reads
their TJ Ward still out there right and
a lot of people are saying Oh everyone's
up against them you think it's because
of a different issue I do I do think
it's not it's so just the list you said
right there right all those guys have
issues that these are not superstar
safeties of the world like did Kenny
Vaccaro get anointed as a superstar I
think I think the era creer agreed one
we know the reason Trey Boston and DJ
Ward and those bright TJ Ward it's about
over his bodies just falling apart man
so it's he's got like you know it's the
Bob Sanders thing when you're that size
and you're that explosive and you hit
exactly right left go your body is just
gonna fall apart so his career I think
is on the downturn if not gonna be the
last year if not over already tyvan
branch Mike Mitchell right again Mike
Mitchell up there an age a little bit
play wasn't stellar to where they're
like oh my gosh we have to have him on
the field right Whitner okay so yeah
that's not he's gonna be done everything
was more about their style so this is
what I was gonna say so yes all these
free agents have issues right we just
kind of mentioned all them none of them
are just superstar slam dunk type of
guys I think that's the first
thing I would look at none of them are
like special athletes we're not looking
at anybody there I'm going all wide mean
he's one of the fastest safeties in
football how could he not be out there
so the safety market yeah it's not great
but I would argue this there's only a
handful of special safeties that's a
special skill set to be an earl thomas
or eric berry or a camp chancellor or a
key an O'Neill I mean if we go through
football I we can sit here and go
through teams right now I know we can go
through the special safeties in football
take tho was it from a coverage person
and that's where I'm getting to I'm
getting there and and I wrote and teams
err on coverage more these days so the
Mike Mitchell's and the Trey Boston's a
scheme fit he's great for the Seattle
scheme and that's where he kicked ass
like in the bar safety right physical
but when he was in Carolina nobody
trusted him in coverage because he had
to play the deep path things like that
he wasn't as great at that so again the
schemes aren't out there for him to fit
in it right now and I think that goes
and yes we're seeing third safety on the
field we'll just bring Erick Rowan he's
big he can tackle and we know he can
play a tight end man-to-man so I think
you're seeing some of those guys that
were big corners are taking their jobs
as safeties right whether it be
transferring to that in college or the
NFL either way so I think that's another
thing and I wrote one of the other
things I wrote into my little text to
you none of these free agent guys they
all have coverage issues every single
one of them Kenny Vaccaro they were
trying to trade a master who got burned
regularly yes I mean right all of them
have coverage issues so this day and age
where we're talking about the helmet
problem and spearing and all those
things right that guy no we'll just air
him the guy that we think can cover
Gronk or you know cover kareem hunt out
of the backfield on third down I thought
it would do that I thought it was very
fitting as I was collecting my news from
around the NFL that the Texans announced
that Kareem Jackson was moving to say
there you go
exactly so moving a corner to safety
because they tried him out there because
of injuries at the end of last year
they went you know this actually worked
it's pretty good yes he can cover
he doesn't have to knock people's heads
off you think the style of the game yeah
which one do you think impacted more the
fact that we're getting so many shifty
slot receivers mm and it's become such a
passing league or because the penalties
and the running game or is it a
collection of all of it yeah I think
it's a little collection of all of it
but I think the biggest thing is the the
animals were seeing in the NFL we
haven't seen before whether it's a
shifty slot receiver or the big awesome
calf pass-catching tight end that's
making it shift so the thumping safety
might be died it for it's gonna be
looked upon less rarely it's gonna be
for certain scenarios yeah it's gonna be
for certain teeth jerilyn that's why
German James was on the board at 19 for
the Chargers it's just because there's
nothing there's 17 whatever but it's not
a lot of guys or teams that are valuing
that as much because I think they look
at it the guy that can cover ground and
cover more is a little bit safer than
you know the multiple personnel sets the
no-huddle stuff all of that stuff yeah
the you know so-called big Ronnie lots
of the world okay yeah okay they were
great in the box but all the sudden the
next spike Branca split out and you go
where did we do with this guy he's big
he's strong whatever but he can't run in
space so I think that's really the big
issue and again I mean special safeties
in football I just would like to special
we're talking about special right okay
I'm gonna say Devin McCourty special I'm
gonna go through every team right here
Devin McCourty special Pittsburgh
Steelers I don't think have a special
safety Shawn Davis is a good player I'm
not wrong home special yet the
Jacksonville Jaguars as good as their
safeties are I'm not calling them
special hey Shawn Gibson and Barry
Church are good right Kansas City Chiefs
yep Chiefs they got a special one Byard
who I would say for the Tennessee Titans
he's on the cusp of maybe being special
not gonna go there yet Buffalo Bills I
think there's some good ones but special
no Baltimore I don't I'm not calling
Eric Weddle special people always seem
to call him I know but it's it's what
year is it for him 11 yeah I mean come
on he's not special anymore is this real
good player
the chargers they have German James who
could be special but again no does
Cincinnati Bengals they don't have
anybody the Raiders don't have anybody
Miami
Rashad Jones no he's not special anymore
in my book he's really good really good
right so I'm just trying to special
right exactly Denver Broncos I don't
think they have a special safety New
York Jets do Jamal Adams and maybe the
other guy they might have to Marcus may
Colts nobody Houston got team
honeybadger special but I would even say
that he has to prove a special prove it
again you're right so it's a yes you're
right so I would say that so there
there's that team's alright and I'll
just run through the NFC really quick
Philadelphia
Malcolm Jenkins probably he's just on
the special line yes just on it okay
Minnesota Vikings Harrison Smith special
Rams no Landon Collins Landon Collins
for sure Panthers no Ken O'Neal yes
okay Detroit's got nobody Seattle Earl
Thomas okay I'll put him in the special
fans he's not calling clover Quinn no
but he's just saying he's handsome
I'm just saying yes he's a very good
player I'm trying to different to the
special people Arizona doesn't anybody
right now Green Bay doesn't have anybody
right now you should watch out for that
Josh Jones LaMarcus Joyner for the Rams
is on the cusp that's what I was saying
him for him Washington no Niners no
maybe a jack Watsky tart no he's not but
he's not there yeah I gotta let you call
him specials other guys yeah right Tampa
no Chicago no no so Landon Collins yes
so that's what I'm saying so the market
their dirt the market I think is what
it's supposed to be is what I'm saying
it is interesting it's just the air so
long no the air crew you just love
ranking the safeties Eric Reid makes it
all seem like there's another motive
yeah and what you're saying is no you
guys just don't do what the NFL needs
right now right yes
and they just don't realize that right I
have a guarantee that Patrick mahomes
was gonna have an amazing year guarantee
because somebody said he wasn't because
Danny canal doesn't have faith this guy
Danny canal was the one that at halftime
was like you're gonna bench the
quarterback you've had all year for Toa
four - oh whatever
alright and then everyone's like yeah
Danny canal said about Patrick mahomes
he inherited the keys not just to any
old car
this is a Ferrari my big concern is as a
rookie okay
yeah you make a lot of mistakes you try
to do too much to turn the ball over and
people wonder hey do we get rid of Alex
Smith who was the picture of consistency
in the NFL was this a mistake
I wonder if he can live up to those
expectations I will take any bet against
Patrick mahomes yeah
if you out there and I've seen other
comments like this the popular notion is
he hasn't done anything what if this
goes bad sure if you are selling stock
and Patrick mahomes I am buying bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye Patrick mahomes I
have so much faith in this commutative I
have so much faith in Andy Reid I have
so much faith in the weapons around him
I liked what I saw the end of last year
they're just stories not connecting
great with Sammy Watkins okay fine III
will bet anybody any amount of money
that Patrick mahomes will play well next
okay so we didn't but to see this is
where I always laugh at people oh yeah I
mean I'm with you I'm on your you know
me I'm up sell me stock but this is
where I feel like people don't hear what
comes out of their mouth it's a Ferrari
so in essence it's gonna be easier but
it's a Ferrari but it's a model of
consistency that no but that hasn't done
[ __ ] in the playoffs but let's just keep
doing it I mean damn it's consistent
yeah well consistent ain't gonna get it
done in the playoffs he doesn't in six
yeah every year right and you know he's
a wooden one in the 2017 playoffs and
all in one of the 2016 playoffs and oh
he was one in one in the 2015 playoffs
Alex Smith did play pretty well in the
first half of the priest of the playoff
game against the Titans he was actually
Fenton I said that's so that's what
we're gonna hold it accountable to when
I get it I can have it kind of fell
apart a little bit right so I just I
just so again no I agree with you we
have always said that for the Chiefs to
reach the next level they need to move
on from Alex Smith yes it's not I'm not
trying to be a jerk here but this is a
team like he said it's a Ferrari okay
but it's been driven
like it was a 4-wheel Jeep Wrangler and
mahomes is actually gonna be able to get
to cylinder 8 9 10 11 and 12 to make
that car go 220 for the first time ever
now is he gonna throw some interceptions
and things like that certainly he's
gonna make mistakes but the purpose of
why they drafted Patrick mahomes was
because in big games against really
quality defenses you need a quarterback
that can make some plays that the
offensive systems not gonna make to get
you over the hump and that's what he's
gonna do I mean again 2013 let me just
make sure here it's 38 to 10 Kansas City
Chiefs in the wild-card game against the
Colts against the Colts they lost 45 to
44 they sweat so they went they were on
a 35 scored 35 to 6
so again consistencies great but at some
point during the clutch moments of the
game your quarterbacks got to be
big-time like we've seen Brady or some
of these guys do so many times I think I
think you nailed it with this
why are you gonna continuously make the
same mistake every year right it's time
to address that of course Patrick
mahomes was gonna throw more
interceptions in Alex Smith Alex Smith
has checked down charlie yeah he prides
himself on not turning it over but guess
what we're past that yeah you need a guy
that's gonna push the envelope and if he
doesn't then we're right back where they
were
exactly oh the Ferrari uses gas faster
yeah it could also go a lot faster
zactly so yes there's gonna be a
downside yes he might throw a pick he's
his rookie year we always judge these
guys way too quickly I know but his
potential is so much higher than Alex
Smith and we've already seen as far as
Alex Smith can take us we've seen it yes
you're right we've already seen it up
that butthole gets tight in the playoffs
and he can't do it no no I think that's
that's why I think the route Washington
will be a good regular season team yeah
I have a lot of faith in my divisional
rankings but when it's time to get to
the playoffs man they're not going
anywhere that's right I love Alex it's
not all on him yeah let's J draws I said
some stuff going out of them right
that's right but I trust naggy and Reid
I mean they had it I agree
all right so we're gonna end with
one final question if there's no wrong
answer but we're gonna I'm gonna try and
find MD glad you're wearing a blue shirt
today you know you saw there you saw
what do you try to put me in such cases
good yeah yeah we saw a picture today
like I missed fat laughs yeah that was
great
I don't love handles let's go you're in
the red zone and there's point zero one
seconds left on the clock
point zero one there's no doesn't exist
in football the [ __ ] up MD who are you
throwing to this is not based on their
quarterback or the offensive scheme its
quarterback Chris says okay Antonio
Brown DeAndre Hopkins Julio Jones Odell
Beckham oh so it's your last throw in
the red zone who are you going with my
answer surprised me your answer was
probably DeAndre Hopkins and I
understand that because in this
conversation and this scenario he comes
into play right yeah because he's a
great back shoulder traffic tow tipper
like you always say credible sideline
right exactly so and it's bigger than
all of them he is I don't know is he's
bigger than Julio
I'll check right yeah I don't think he
is I keep Who Wants to Be a Millionaire
in this handsome yeah but this is that
what I was doing
yeah no I think it's a that's a really
good one all right so it was a B Julio
DeAndre and who else was there the other
one my Motel hotel sorry okay um man
gosh that is you can't lose with any of
them DeAndre is very much in this
conversation as much as I don't think
DeAndre is really in the conversation
with these guys shocked what I am
shocked
how tall is Julio Jones just give it to
me height I think Julio's six two and a
half six three okay how tall is DeAndre
Hopkins I think he's I think it was six
one and a half he's 6 1 I am shocked cuz
his arms like he can scratch his knees
without standing up he's got incredibly
big hands in low arms L is 511 right
that shocked people in the office people
the office thought he was 6 - right
Antonio's 510 yeah he might even be 5 9
but but 6 1 I thought Hopkins was 6 for
I am shocked I know alright well now I'm
not sure I know I told you all right so
listen to me you think I was wrong
no it's been a while no but keep talking
through though so what are you looking
for with 0.01 seconds well yeah I am I
wanted somebody that can make miraculous
jump jump ball 50/50 type catches and
Antonio can do that all the balls like
you just said to start this there's no
rules I'm gonna go with Odell Beckham
jr. because I still think he's the best
combination of everything we're talking
about you know okay he might not be the
best toe tapper but he's right up there
okay
50/50 balls I don't know I mean he might
be the best I mean when I watch Eli
Manning highlights I think Hopkins is
really really close it's really good so
this is where I think I take Odell are
they both better than Julio and 5050
because I think Julio jumped over Erik
run yeah no but I think as a true 5050
jump ball catcher's I think they are
better than hooli what about Antonio we
just wrote off in China right I think
Antonio actually might be a better 50/50
ball catcher to than then Julio as that
is but Antonio has a knack for it I
think the other thing too that I you
know what are you looking for in the
Reds well the Reds are right I also want
precise route running which is gonna be
mandatory Oh brown
tonio or Odell their arm a little more
precise than the other two yeah Hopkins
is more like we're on the block we're
lobbing it up that exactly right or just
make it maybe one cut so yes you Miguel
you a post corner post hotel so del
you're running a post corner which is in
and then out right or you're going alan
host corner post right you can do double
like you can do stuff like that with a
Julio and I mean uh Antonio in Odell
yeah so what do you is that the same
route you're running with Antonio yes
something like that I could do that but
you could also go jump balls the other
thing I look at them and go like where
DeAndre Hopkins doesn't have okay it's
one on one of the teams in a blitz me
all out and but all these receivers are
in the slot and the the slot receivers
gonna run a corner around to the back
part of the end zone
Odell and Antonio Julio I feel like I
can throw it to the back pylon and
they're gonna want to go get it DeAndre
I'd go ooh I might need to see his break
because he can't run to the level the
other three can again that's where I
think DeAndre behind these guys
go find clips of diandra having yak
that's my that's a thing wheel is not
here I know I'm just saying that but I'm
just saying that's where he hurts his
overall plan your big thing is if it's
an all-out blitz
you're worried with Hopkins ability to
get off the line clean and sprint to
that to go track a ball you know it's
down to a B and holy yeah I mean oh baby
you know I think I would go with Odell
so I know I'm a homer with Odell it's
hard for me not to because Odell I also
look at Odell and Antonio and go the
quick screen is very much available for
them to I'm on the 8 yard line you could
throw them a quick bubble screen they
can make to people my surprise most you
the next time you're in a quick bubble
screen with 0.01 on the clock I'm
getting it in the end zone right short
it should be yeah my mind first went to
Hopkins I know what you mean but I will
say that Antonio Brown at the end of
last year his catches on Monday Night
Football Thursday Night Football in the
back of the endzone what amazing and
then also the 50/50 balls against
Jacksonville yeah Antonio better than
any of them doesn't reveal to the
secondary to the defensive back hands
that balls coming yes Hawkins and Odell
are like you ready to gently go up again
it was like I'm gonna jump over you
right Antonio is like not even looking
right and then he turns and catches it
falls pocket right which is incredible
it is incredible I also would say again
you know my point there Ben
Roethlisberger's one of the greatest
downfield throwers ever right so now
you're throwing the ball probably not
gonna be as well what a dick see you
later I'm gonna end with this I wasn't
gonna bring this up but an amazing early
2000s battle between two former Florida
Gators Ledo Shepherd and Jabar Gaffney I
saw this well I heard I mean you know
apparently poured something in his Ledo
Shepards gas tank and then his
girlfriend popped his tires and I just
thought you know you've told the Jabar
Gaffney Soup story hey Jabbar don't take
I don't even know the history of this
story I know nothing about he went to
high school together
they went to college together right
worth writing now it's a long-standing
feud from 2012 but it just reminded me
that you've watched Jabar Gaffney pour
soup on somebody's head exactly what
poor burning
Otsu Jabar Gaffney we'll take crap from
no one like he is truly like when I
think of the movie Fight Club and
they're in the bathroom scene and he's
like who would you fight in history and
remember Brad Pitt cuz I'd fight Abraham
Lincoln skinny guys fight to the death
that's Jabar Gaffney he's like one of
those he's like one of those I mean this
is a good way one of those idiots it's
like what you're six six 350 [ __ ] you
I'll fight you I don't care like he's
got that kind of attitude yeah
what was the soup story again Wesley
Woodyard he kept getting out of thee so
Wesley when you would get out of the
shower as you just started to dry off
he'd run out there and throw soap on you
right like liquid soaps he had to go
back in to rinse it off I know it was
fun those are things that go on in the
locker room I mean come on
whoa Jabbar I think one too many times
and Jabbar he did it to Jabbar and
Jabbar won the one time goes hey man you
do that again we're fighting that's what
he said
well like few days later Wesley Dena he
decided toed the line he did it again
and this time Jabbar didn't go back in
the shower
he just got dressed he put on his sweats
and soap off with the soap on his back
and like drip and Danny put his sweats
on he put some flip-flops and he walked
out of the locker room and I knew he was
pissed I was watching I was like oh man
Japs pissed like and a few minutes went
by too and Wesley would yours Locker was
not far from jab and he was sitting
there at his locker
and jab came in with two bowls of soup
and dumped it on his head and then Wes
got up and was like kind of flustered
another guy and he saw Jabbar and Jabbar
was like yo [ __ ]
told you we were fight and he was there
with his fists up and Wesley charged at
him and they threw blows to end did he
have burns like very minor but yes he
did have burns yes but the fact that
someone doesn't have the decision-making
to not pour hot soup on someone's head
what could have happened I know but I
also I would he handle it I don't think
anybody said anything I don't think you
ever knew yo you talk about locker you
it's prison rules that's what I mean
he's he's Wesley Woodyard is wrong he's
the wrong one you were warned that there
was gonna be an issue if you did it
again as a man in the locker room when
the
man says that to you you just got to
know it's like goes back to me with my
Adam Hayward story that I've told you
about in Tampa
Adam Hayward look him up Adam Hayward
I've told you this story before I used
to mess around he's a rookie right he
was a middle linebacker special teamer
and I would play with the rookies every
now that and him he was a good dude I
started poking him on the head he didn't
like it he got in my face he goes you do
it again I'm gonna kick your ass I said
okay I'll never do it again cuz I know
he would've kicked my ass I was gonna
mess with him your salt you saw did you
yes so I said okay there's the line
that's the locker room rule I went up to
it I know not to push him there again if
I get my ass whooped again because I did
it I deserve to get my ass well how this
sounds like a frequent thing not of you
but of locker rooms if everyone pushes
the line a little bit yeah then
everybody got Oakes we have fun we have
things like that and then it's a bunch
of dumb male meatheads and someone
always pushes it too far so you've seen
a few of these people snap definitely
yes yes typically rookies I was I
snapped once on Dave Dave Aude defensive
lineman in Tennessee he came in throwing
snowballs at people in the bathroom
which was cool but he busted someone and
then he's do another one it was like a
ice body has busted me in the head and I
went off on him and he was like chill
bro you know he wasn't chill he was like
[ __ ] you Sims you wanna fight it I was
like [ __ ] no I don't want to fight you
you're 290 you're gonna kick my ass and
everybody laughter yes Sims that reverse
psychology I knew my place so the
coaches typically they stay out all of
us yeah they have no jurisdiction there
meanwhile girls like coaches have no
jurisdiction in locker room do you mean
but like when they come to the locker
room they gotta be ready to take you
know this shut up and walk through you
know that's it what do you mean I just
know I imagine that when the coach
walked through it was like head coach
might get a little of like oh just like
Keith quietly in the locker room no it's
kind of like one of those things very
rare see this is really quality today
this is this is an inside football thing
that I didn't realize okay I assume that
the coach puts on his socks right there
they got their own little special
locker room the coach so the locker room
is like your free playground anything
goes whoo and whoever's the leader the
team rules the roofs right d-line runs
the radio it juris it's a it police's
itself so Java sure walks into the
locker room yeah I mean he you know what
he probably he wouldn't walk by less he
walked through unless he really had him
he wouldn't know he was a next player
it's been like I'm not I don't need to
mess with that Gruden yeah okay maybe in
a media obligation it'll walk through
the locker he walked through it but guys
didn't spend their time - the other
thing that happened and like you know I
don't know people who do our quality
control might not like this but if you
walk through the locker room too many
times and you're not one of them yeah oh
you're gonna get made fun of so when
people that were like any like walking
through like to get from point A to
point B or just checking on ya know no
they're just like Gruden or a coach just
walking through cuz they had to walk
through to get to point A to point B
they're not really walking there for any
specific reason and talked to a player
or anything
yes that's like a thing that when a
coach walks through that's their domain
so because what's weird is coaches
aren't gonna tell you to turn the music
down or anything like that when I watch
the postgame celebrations yeah and
they're breaking down the locker room
right I just assume that the coach is
always in the lock now yeah he the times
that the coach is in there right and he
walks out before the game gives you a
little speck pep pep talk after the game
good job Bubba Bob you know work on this
I'll see you this time tomorrow and he
walks out of the locker room and goes
into his room and does what he has to do
yeah I know it's kind of weird you're I
I never thought about it and so you
started having me talk about it
so balichek wouldn't go in there no I
just again maybe a casual walk through
because it had to go to the coach's
meeting rooms maybe from the press room
or whatever but no he wasn't gonna hang
out in there and you weren't gonna have
any long football discussions in there
either like you coaches weren't gonna
stop by and like oh let's talk about
technique they're gonna be okay when you
get dressed and shower it up and
everything you know get some food and
bring it in my room we'll talk so it's a
little solace it's a little paradise for
playing a little bit yes that's their
Haven it's to get back get healthy get
away from the coaches yeah cool tub hot
tub whatever all that stuff awesome
yeah learn something new every day there
you go all right Sims a left go
everybody out there you guys are amazing
keep hitting us up at Sims and left go
Sims is date is officially on
28 July 28th that is when Sims is
guessing Odell will get the new contract
I will enter that if you have an entrant
yet get in there we will give away swag
so guys thank you so much as always we
are gonna be recording again on
Wednesday for Sims peace out homies
federic would say good evening in the
lef koe man says holla holla holla holla
holla holla guys whoa big offseason
enjoy it well holler just soon be well